[Music]
in permanent opponent tournament
tournament submitted by whoa dude whoa
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] a cheating husband
does the most to earn back his wife's
trust cut off his dick oh ho ho
[ __ ] but they had nice to meet you to
watch me Batman he's a why he's
pointless now yeah good one yeah so this
uh this dude his name is Jose Canseco
remember him
no that's Canseco I think you a baseball
guy this photo went around I saw it on
Instagram this is what it says
so this is a tattoo a permanent tattoo
Jamie no no you're good you pronounce it
perfectly all he's part of the small
nipple crew oh yeah why he's so far
apart though they're like on the side
room to Reyes he looks like a
marshmallow so it says I Jose L Torres
I'm getting a tattoo voluntarily On
January 2nd 2019 so that I can earn my
wife's trust back for the pain and
suffering I have caused in our marriage
I am a liar cheater manipulator a
deceiver deceiver deceiver really wrong
he spelled this see bachelor oh my god
poor slash prostitute lover dishonest
and disrespect no
I love all both him and the tattoo
artists didn't catch any of this maybe
the tattoo artist was like hey
something's following he's like nah
leavings that's how I spell it fever
Revis alone and then I was thinking like
how funny like you know that that rule
like I before E except after season and
remember that in this room quite
obviously yeah and then this respect
you'll they forgot the app yeah when you
type this stuff and the red squiggly
comes up you should right-click that
[ __ ] exactly it would have been
funny if he had the squid the right
squeezes oh oh yeah you should go back
they could actually fix the disrespect
no they can not remember the no regret
yeah I love misspelled tattoos they're
the favorite just happen in a move yeah
yeah no regret but yeah so I was playing
too because the person or like they
ended up posting this on Instagram and
it's the caption said nothing like some
nice lettering to start the year and
then after doesn't parentheses just to
clarify I didn't know the tattoo was
misspelled until they started talking
about it wrote that well I keep tagged
someone else I don't know who was the
one that did the tattoo so is he
forgiven yeah oh yeah can you imagine
being the girlfriend and you like or the
wife or whatever and then you make him
get that tattoo and then you leave his
ass anyway that would be money or he's
gonna have to get a big-ass [ __ ]
cover-up and like I gonna cover up a
letter like that stomach tattoo is hurt
- do you know what everyone tells me
there's a lot why were you thinking
about getting a stomach test no but
everyone just tells me they're just like
it's the most paint one of the most
painful places really I thought it was
like most people with the bone area not
for me not for me are these just like
what the points are sensitive you know
you that are ticklish
you don't get that much contact it just
hurts so much that way they say it hurts
a lot here yeah I heard the armpit is a
mother it does there's a cream with no
parts I have some that come in here and
those parts it was like I wanted to
punch that fall in the face oh yeah
even those my idea I never thought about
stomach tattoos
I've always liked tattoos on so many
different parts of the body but like I
never thought about name on here - yeah
Tupac never influenced you to get thug
life on your stomach yeah I don't think
it was a cool place to get a tattoo I
know they said to make sense it was look
even more like way more whose just
tattoo a ruler from a wonderful guys
that have tiny nipples their nipples are
really far apart though like I feel like
that's the thing I think it also looks
more far apart well yeah cuz it's small
but then if they don't have pecs like if
their pecs aren't built it just looks
like concave and then like spread out
cuz is don't look that far it's shoulder
boy baby look see they don't look that
far apart they do do look pretty far
apart
good thing cuz they're popping out
through the shoes I could redo them give
me a marker look weird and you go to
clothes any drier eyebrows - cool yeah I
just feel bad for the tattoo artist
that's a lot of words and they're small
- right and he's getting paid shit's
gonna bleed together - oh yeah cuz it's
so close together like [ __ ] that's true
and then I was thinking of his wife made
him do it
would you like let's say you're the wife
right and you're like man as full as a
liar prostitute lover a deceiver she
said a prostitute oh yeah better it
looks like he used to have bigger pecs
and then they shrink no but then yeah so
I'm thinking like what she want her own
name on there cuz imagine her name was
on there like my wife like a contract
because we did he write his own name on
his stomach yeah I post it oh no no down
there yeah that again I'll say why would
you put your own name on your body I
don't understand that concept about that
you need a way of identifying him in a
gang war
this is Jose or
name he was probably thinking he was
probably she's giving me head she sees
my name on my stomach Paul say there's a
saggy belly bit would you ever get that
sir I do I've been falling so many times
about to say I do have one oh yeah
surprises Julia you I've been looking at
some and oh my gosh I'm in love I just
don't know how to tattoo yeah what do
you want
don't say Pikachu no no you can say
whatever you want it's like it's like
this Chinese ink painting style like
watercolor styling I only loved those
types of taxes Oh like the horse like
they do the horse would just eat like
the and like I just been looking at a
lot of ones I wanted in color right yeah
I wanted in color yeah so there's been a
lot I've been following a lot of Asian
tattoo are you gonna take the you can do
it or not I just don't think you know
I'm still I'm still looking I'm still
thinking about it I'm trying to solidify
like what artwork I would be cool with
to like keep on my body forever yeah
yeah I'm thinking about it like I would
like to but I just know that because my
tastes change all the time I was like I
don't know if I want something permanent
same you should check out the Chinese
tattoo artists that are coming out right
now because a lot of them are like
classically trained like painters and
all that for many [ __ ] years and then
they start picking up the Machine and
and so they're doing some like crazy ass
[ __ ] on tattoos like they're changing
the game it's because there's all
Chinese name so I don't remember but
it's [ __ ] say the reason why I still
haven't gotten one either is because the
tattoo Styles changed so much and I'm
gonna be like dang I love a style that's
now and then but I got this old style
you know what's cool you have so much
skin on your body I don't want to be all
tatted up so you can get another one
in a different place and a sick-ass
story Tony took us Clark it's like this
moment in time I did this there's a lot
of I feel like styles that are kind of
timeless though like cuz I feel like a
sleeve like you have like that's not
gonna really be like oh my god this
so 90s you know like like if you're into
tattoos you could tell well this is a
sleeve of a [ __ ] tribal tattoo like
the the barbed wire or that [ __ ] right
yeah I think you know y'all remember
those stars it was like a most oh no no
the email stars get red and black I
could get like to the family famous
family yeah I think so yeah well that's
like where the black that one red and
black are like black and I think if you
just do your own [ __ ] because you liked
it for the sake of lighting that's the
important thing
yeah then I bet she don't even because
that defies all turns on it yeah yeah
yet to feel like [ __ ] I regret it like
I've never regretted it yeah they don't
look like cheesy though so I mean you
made good choices thank you for not me
my first tattoo was all a sixteen and I
got my last name on my chest and in the
other one I learned how to tattoo but I
didn't learn how to shade so I never
finished it
it still looks cool watch that video of
you talking oh yeah so there's a story I
guess cuz I tattooed myself it was cool
your name one is okay no it's not like
it looks cool it's it cuz for Americans
you know like it's cool for us but if I
really think about it like it's lame
being Japanese and writing that it's
just like if if if you just put Caldwell
on your chest like with regular comic
stands just like like you don't say like
it's just it's just Jessica Old English
on your back and then he said Comic Sans
and that's the [ __ ] change or like
it's like it's like Jessica and it's
like Ariel like are like regular [ __ ]
she's a girl
no normal Arial font like regular like
the most basic [ __ ] tattoos not that
it's not like the goofy talk show font
it's not the worst but it is like a
nametag if you think about it right it's
it's just I don't know I was sick I was
like sixteen or I was 15 or 16
[Applause]
in like Asian culture kind of seems like
it holds a little bit more weight then I
guess the white culture so it seems like
oh that's cool you got your family name
on you yeah oh he did it I also did it
to not remember get how it's written
[Music]
wait a second damn momento
[Music]